foreign
this is Professor of the science and
today we will discuss the Pauli matrices
in another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics the Paulie matrices
are named after volgang Paoli one of the
fathers of quantum mechanics and perhaps
best known for the eponymous power the
Exclusion Principle there are three poly
matrices of Dimension two by two and
while they may look simple we simply
cannot overstate their importance in
Quantum Mechanics for example they play
an absolutely Central role in the study
of spin one-half particles such as the
electron and they're also the starting
point to study any Quantum system that
can be described with a two-dimensional
State space in this video we will Define
the poly matrices and we will explore
some of their most useful mathematical
properties so let's go
let's go straight to the definition of
the Paulie matrices
they are usually labeled with the Greek
letter Sigma and the first one is Sigma
one with entries 0 1 1 0.
the second one is Sigma 2 with entries 0
minus I I zero
and the third one is Sigma 3 with
entries one zero zero minus one
these matrices play a key role in
various areas of quantum mechanics
perhaps the most famous of which is for
the description of spin one-half
particles like the electron
but more generally they're also a
building block for the description of
any Quantum system with a
two-dimensional State space
given how widespread they are the aim of
this video is pretty straightforward
we're going to derive some of the most
important mathematical properties of all
of these pounding matrices
for Pali matrices are hermitian and
remember that an operator or Matrix a is
her Mission if it is equal to its at
joint
so let's confirm this explicitly by
starting with the sigma 1 Matrix up here
the adjoint of a matrix is defined as
the complex conjugate of the transverse
in this case the transpose is trivially
the same and then we just need to take
the complex conjugate
as the entries of the sigma 1 Matrix are
real The Matrix is again unchanged so
the final result is the Matrix 0 1 1 0.
and indeed this sequel to Sigma 1.
let's try Sigma 2 which is slightly more
interesting
the at joint of Sigma 2 is again equal
to the transpose of the Matrix and then
the complex conjugate which flips the
signs of the imaginary terms to get this
which is indeed equal to Sigma 2.
finally for the adjoint of Sigma 3 we
calculate the transpose conjugate which
is once again trivial to evaluate as the
Matrix is real and we get Sigma 3.
these relations explicitly confirm that
the Paulie matrices are hermitian
the next property that we will
investigate is the fact that the Paulie
matrices are involuntary which remember
means that an operator or Matrix a is
equal to its own inverse
to show this explicitly we will
demonstrate that multiplying a powerly
matrix by itself yields the identity
so let's take Sigma 1 squared first
we can write it out explicitly as Sigma
1 times Sigma 1. and applying the usual
rules of matrix multiplication we get
one zero zero one which is the two by
two identity Matrix
this confirms that the inverse of the
sigma 1 Matrix is itself
so moving on to Sigma t squared we
explicitly get this
applying the usual rules of matrix
multiplication we end up with minus I
squared 0 0 minus I squared which
reduces to 1 0 0 1 which is indeed the
identity Matrix
for Sigma 3 squared we explicitly get
this
multiplying we get one zero zero minus
one all squared and again that reduces
to one zero zero one which is again the
identity Matrix
these relations confirm that the Paulie
matrices are their own inverses
and here I'm using the sub index K to
refer to a generic poly Matrix so K runs
from 1 to 3.
in the previous light we've already
established that the Paulie matrices are
hermitian
bringing these two insights together we
can conclude that the inverters of the
Pauli matrices are equal to their at
joints which means that the powerly
matrices are also unitary
next we're going to look at the
determinant of the Pali matrices
for a general two by two Matrix a
the determinant is really easy to
calculate we just multiply the two
diagonal elements together and then
subtract the multiplication of the two
of diagonal terms
with this the determinant of the sigma 1
Matrix is 0 minus 1 which is -1
the determinant of the segment 2 Matrix
is zero minus minus I squared which is
-1
and the determinant of the sigma 3
Matrix is minus one minus zero which is
also minus one
so all powerly matrices have the same
determinant which is minus one
great so the next property we're going
to study is the trace of the Pauline
matrices
for a general two by two Matrix a
the trace is simply the sum of the
diagonal elements
we can trivially see that the trace of
Sigma 1 is 0.
the trace of Sigma 2 is also zero and
the trace of Sigma 3 is 1 minus one
which is also zero
so that means that all the parody
matrices are traceless
let's move on to the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors of the pounding matrices
and this is a bit more exciting perhaps
we'll take the sigma 1 poly Matrix as an
example and write its eigenvalue
equation
as always these Lambda are the
eigenvalues and these V the eigenvectors
to find the eigenvalues we need to
consider the characteristic equation of
Sigma 1.
the terms in Brackets here are the sigma
1 Matrix minus Lambda times the identity
Matrix
which evaluates to minus Lambda 1 1
minus Lambda so we therefore need to
evaluate the determinant of this Matrix
and set it to zero
we have the product of the diagonal
terms minus the product of the of
diagonal terms equal to zero and this
leads to Lambda equals two plus minus
one
therefore the eigenvalues of the sigma 1
powerly Matrix are plus one and -1
so let's make some room
starting with the eigenvalue plus one we
can write out the corresponding
eigenvalue equation where I am now
labeling the eigenvector V with the sub
index plus to indicate that it
corresponds to the plus one eigenvalue
writing this out we get this Matrix
equation
we can multiply these two terms together
to end up with this column Vector on the
left hand side equal to the column
Vector representing the eigenvector
comparing the first entry here with the
first entry here we arrive at the
conclusion that V2 plus is equal to V1
Plus
therefore the normalized eigenvexor is
equal to 1 over square root of two times
the vector 1 1.
repeating the same exercise for the
eigenvalue minus one we would find that
the normalized eigenvector is equal to
this expression
let's make some room again
we've now established that for the
Apparently Matrix Sigma 1 the
eigenvalues are plus one with this
normalized eigenvexor
and minus one with this other normalized
eigenvector
I would encourage you to repeat the same
exercise for the other two Paulie
matrices but what we will do here is to
Simply quote the final results for Sigma
2 we also have that the eigenvalues are
plus one and minus one and we get this
eigenvector for plus one
and this eigenvector four minus one
and for Sigma 3 we also have that the
eigenvalues r plus one and minus one and
the eigenvector for plus one is one zero
and the eigenvector for minus one is
zero one
we're now going to consider the
commutation relations between the paroly
matrices and remember that the
commutator of two matrices or operators
A and B is equal to a B minus b a
we will look at a particular example the
commutator of Sigma 1 and sigma 2. we
can expand out this expression to get
Sigma 1 Sigma 2 minus Sigma 2 Sigma 1.
focusing on the first term we can spell
it out by writing Sigma 1 and sigma 2.
using matrix multiplication we get I
zero zero minus I
now for the second term we now first
spell out Sigma 2 and then Sigma 1. and
multiplying we obtain minus I zero zero
I
going back to the commutator we need
this product Sigma 1 Sigma 2 which gives
this term
mine is a product Sigma 2 Sigma 1 which
gives this other term
so evaluating this expression we obtain
2i 0 0 minus 2i which we can simplify as
2i multiplying The Matrix one zero zero
minus one
so we see that this Matrix is actually
Sigma 3 and we end up with 2i Sigma 3.
so overall going back to the top the
commutator of Sigma 1 and sigma 2 is
equal to 2i Sigma 3.
let's make some ROM
we could repeat this exercise for all
other possible pairs of poly matrices
and again I am going to really encourage
you to try it out because it's a great
way to get familiar with operator
algebra but what we are going to do
today is to Simply write out the final
result which is that the commutator
between Sigma 2 and sigma 3 is equal to
2i times Sigma 1 and the commutator
between Sigma 3 and sigma 1 is equal to
2i times Sigma 2. and all other
commutators will vanish trivially
for example the commutator of Sigma 1
with itself is equal to zero
we can summarize these Expressions as
the commutator of Sigma J and sigma K
being equal to 2i times the sum over L
of Epsilon jkl times Sigma l and where J
K and L can take any value of 1 2 and 3.
this term here is called the levy
trevita symbol
if you've encountered the levy chivita
symbol before that's great
if not all you need to know is that the
Levi chivita symbol is defined such that
when the sub indices are all different
and they appear in the order one two
three or any cyclic permutation of that
then it is equal to 1.
if all supin disease are different but
they appear in a cycle that does not
have the order one two three then it is
equal to -1
and for all other combinations it is
equal to zero
now whether you've encountered the levy
chavita symbol before or not you should
convince yourself that the compact
expression here does indeed deliver all
the relations that we have explicitly
outlined up here
overall these commutation relations
should look familiar if you followed our
videos on angular momentum and indeed
the Pauli matrices are intimately
related to the theory of spin angular
momentum four spin one-half particles
like the electron and to learn more
about this you can watch our videos on
spin
finally let's consider the
anti-commutation relations between the
Pauli matrices and first remember that
the anti-communcator of two matrices or
operators A and B is equal to a B plus
ba
we'll again consider a particular
example the anti-communcator of Sigma 1
and sigma 2. we can expand out this
expression to get Sigma 1 Sigma 2 plus
Sigma 2 Sigma 1.
when evaluating the commutator we've
already established that the product
Sigma 1 Sigma 2 is equal to i 0 0 minus
I and the product Sigma 2 Sigma 1 is
minus I zero zeroi
as a result for the anti-commutator we
get this Matrix
plus this Matrix
and they combine to the zero Matrix
overall going back to the top the
anti-commutator of Sigma 1 and sigma 2
is equal to zero
let's make some ROM
we could repeat this exercise for all
other possible pairs of power matrices
and I really encourage you to try it out
but we will again simply write out the
final result which is that the
anti-commutator between Sigma 2 and
sigma 3 is equal to the anti-commutator
between Sigma 3 and sigma 1 and both
vanish
by contrast the anti-commutator between
Sigma 1 with itself is equal to two
times the identity Matrix and so are the
anti-commutators of Sigma 2 with itself
and of Sigma 3 with itself
so we can summarize these Expressions as
the anti-commutator of Sigma J and sigma
K being equal to two times Delta J K
times the identity Matrix where j and k
run from 1 to 3.
this term here is the chronica Delta
symbol
you'll remember that the chronica Delta
symbol is equal to 1 When J equals K and
equals 0 otherwise
let's finish with a brief summary of all
the main results
Pauly matrices are defined as shown up
here they are hermitian involuntary and
unitary
the determinant is equal to -1 and the
trace vanishes
the eigenvalues of all powerly matrices
are plus one and -1
and there eigenvectors are listed here
finally the commutation relations of the
power matrices can be summarized by this
expression
as an example the commutator of Sigma 1
and sigma 2 is equal to 2i times Sigma 3
while the commutator of Sigma 1 and
sigma 1 vanishes
the anti-commutation relations can be
summarized by this expression
and as examples the anti-commutator of
Sigma 1 and sigma 2 vanishes while the
anti-commutator between Sigma 1 and
sigma 1 is equal to 2 times V identity
Matrix
we've introduced several mathematical
properties of the Pauli matrices and you
will see that they will be extremely
useful in our study of quantum mechanics
you can follow some of the links below
to study some of these applications and
that's it for today
if you like the video please subscribe